AND INNOCENCE OF OUR CHILDREN.
AND THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS MISSOURI
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY.
SENATOR, THANKS FOR BEING WITH
US.
THE LEFT TRIED TO WHICH AWAY THE
ISSUE OF CRT IN OUR SCHOOLS IN
VIRGINIA.
AND IT SEEMS TO BE IS ENCASED
HERE.
THEY ARE WISHING THIS AWAY,
LIKE, THIS IS ALL EXAGGERATED.
THIS IS NOT REALLY A PROBLEM.
IT IS ALL ON THE UP AND UP.
BUT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THEY ARE
DEPENDING THE INDEFENSIBLE THEY
WEREN'T -- WON'T TURN BACK.
>> Senator Hawley: ACTUALLY.
THIS IS THE OFFICIAL LINE THAT
CHILD PORNOGRAPHY AND CHILD
EXPORTATION IS A CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT, LAURA.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
SAID IF YOU HAVE CONCERN OF WHAT
YOUR CHILDREN ARE BEING TAUGHT,
YOU ARE A DOMESTIC TERRORIST.
I DON'T THINK THAT SET WELL WITH
VOTERS BASED ON THE ELECTION
RETURNS AND I WOULD SAY THAT
VOTERS THIS NOVEMBER IT WILL
HAVE A SIMILAR CHOICE.
DO YOU WANT A PARTY THAT IS SOFT
ON CRIME AND A PRESIDENT WHO
NOMINATES SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
WHO GIVE CHILD PORNOGRAPHERS AND
CHILD EXPLOITERS A SLAP ON THE
LIST?
>> THIS IS WHAT WE ARE GIVING
PARENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
THEIR STORIES ABOUT WHAT THEY
ARE SEEING IN THEIR SCHOOLS,
EVEN IF THEY ARE AFRAID TO SAY
IT AT HIS BOARD MEETING.
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO TELL US.
THAT IS WHY WE SET UP A REPORT
OF INFORMATION.
TO YOUR POINT THIS DISTURBING
EXCHANGE BETWEEN HARASSMENT
LAUREN BOEBERT TODAY.
WATCH.
>> THE BELIEF THAT A CHILD IS
CAPABLE OF MAKING LIFE ALTERING
DECISIONS TO NAME THEMSELVES?
LET ME JUST THINK OF YOU THAT I
DON'T AGREE WITH YOUR PREMISE.
BUT I WILL SAY IS CHILDREN KNOW
MUCH ABOUT THEMSELVES.
I BELIEVED IN SUPPORTING AND
PROTECTING TRANSGENDER YOUTH AND
I WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT
POLITICIANS LIKE YOU STAY OUT OF
THEIR BUSINESS.
>> Laura: THIS IS SUPPORTING
CHILD ABUSE.
SO WILL YOU CALL FOR HIS
IMMEDIATE REMOVAL JUST OVER THAT
LINE?
>> Senator Hawley: ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THIS IDEA THAT PARENTS
SHOULD BE TOLD BY BUREAUCRATS
HOW TO RAISE THEIR CHILDREN,
THAT PARENTS SHOULD BE TOLD THAT
THE GOVERNMENT KNOWS BEST AND IT
CAN DICTATE TO THEM WHAT IS BEST
FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
THIS IS REALLY A DECISION THAT
PARENTS NEED TO MAKE, PARENTS
KNOW WHAT IS BUT FOR THEIR --
BEST FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
TO HEAR THESE PEOPLE SAY THAT
PARENTS THAT YOU OUGHT TO STEP
BACK.
YOU UP TO STAY OUT OF IT.
YOU ALL TO BE QUIET, I THINK IT
IS CRAZY.
>> Laura: AS A MOTHER, I'M
WATCHING THIS ENTIRE DEBATE
UNFOLD I KEEP SAYING TO MYSELF,
IT IS THIS REALLY AMERICA?
IS THIS REALLY WHERE WE ARE IN
THE COUNTRY?
THE DEBATE OF WHETHER A
FIVE-YEAR-OLD SHOULD BE TAUGHT
THE INTRICACIES OF GENDER
IDENTITY?
AND BY THE WAY, TO THIS POINT
THAT YOU ARE ALLUDING TO
EARLIER, EVERYONE HAS TO HEAR
THE EXCHANGE.
THIS WAS DICK DURBIN RESPONDING
YESTERDAY TO YOUR LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD TOUGHEN SENTENCES FOR
CHILD PORN OFFENSES.
>> WHY DOES THIS SENATOR BRING
THIS TO THE FLOOR OF THE UNITED
STATES SENATE TODAY?
THESE GUIDELINES DON'T REFLECT
THE REALITY OF TODAY.
WE NOW LIVE IN A WORLD OF
INTERNET AND ACCESS TO NOT JUST
TENSE AND HUNDREDS BUT THOUSANDS
OF IMAGES IF THAT IS YOUR
DECISION.
>> Laura: DOESN'T THAT MAKE IT
ACTUALLY MORE PRESSING THAT THIS
LEGISLATION ACTUALLY BE TAKING
UP AND VOTED ON, THAT IS MORE
ACCEPTABLE ENOUGH THAT KIDS CAN
GET EXPLOITED MORE EASILY, MORE
FREQUENTLY BECAUSE THE INTERNET
AND TURBIN IS LIKE, THAT SHOULD
CHANGE NOW.
THINGS ARE DIFFERENT.
>> Senator Hawley: ON THE SOFT
ON CRIME LIBERALS WOULD ASK WHY
YOU NEED TO PROTECT CHILDREN
NOW.
IT IS BECAUSE CHILD EXPORTATION
IS RAMPANT.
IT IS BECAUSE CHILD PORNOGRAPHY
OUR CHILDREN ARE MORE VULNERABLE
THAN I WERE BEFORE BUT YOU
SHOULD NEVER HAVE TO ASK WHY.
THE REASON IS WE HAVE A CRISIS
ON OUR HANDS BUT BY THE WAY, THE
JUDGE JACKSON HEARINGS HAVE ONLY
MADE CLEAR.
JUST HASN'T AGAINST THE PROBLEM
OF CHILD EXPLOITATION AND CHILD
PORNOGRAPHY REALLY IS.
CONGRESS SHOULD EXPECT THEY
SHOULD HAVE ACTED A LONG TIME
AGO BUT THEY SHOULD ACT NOW AND
THIS IS THE TENTH TO GET TOUGH
ON CHILD PORNOGRAPHERS.
THIS IS THE TIME TO GET TOUGH ON
THOSE WHO ABUSE CHILDREN.
PEOPLE CAN EITHER HAVE A PARTY
THAT IS SOFT ON CRIME AND SOFT
ON PEOPLE WHO EXPLOIT CHILD
OFFENDERS WHO ARE CHILD
OFFENDERS OR YOU CAN CHOOSE
SOMEBODY IN THE REPUBLICANS I
HOPE, SAY, LISTEN, WE WILL
PROTECT YOUR CHILDREN.
>> Laura: SENATOR HAWLEY THANK
YOU.
WE WIL